[Applause]
so to the families of the fallen here
and looking on who sacrificed more than
we can comprehend know that the hearts
of every American are with you today and
they'll stay with you every day as will
our prayers we mourn with those who
mourn and grieve with those who grieve
but we do not grieve like those who have
no hope because our faith gives us hope
and heroes give us hope for grow no
greater love has a man than this that he
should lay down his life for his friends
today on Memorial Day we honor Americans
who showed no greater love for the
American people
we can never repay the debt of gratitude
we owe to the men and women who have
given all to preserve our freedom but we
can honor them remember them cherish
their families and this we will do not
just this day but every day and so long
as our nation continues to produce men
and women of such selfless courage and
patriotism I know that freedom will ring
for ourselves and our posterity their
duty was to serve our duty is to
remember this Memorial Day let every
American renew our commitment to do our
duty to never fail never fail to
remember what they've done for us and
never fail to honor and cherish the
families they've left behind and never
fail to strive each and every day to be
worthy of the freedom that they want for
us all may God bless our heroic fallen
may those who mourn our heroes be
comforted until he wipes every tear from
their eyes may God bless the men and
women of our armed forces and may god
bless america
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen please remain
standing for their playing of taps and
the benediction also please remain
standing for the singing of Amazing
Grace performed by the United States
Army chorus
[Music]
you
you
received the benediction go into the
world to preserve peace
remember the wisdom that we have learned
and be courageous pursue excellence in
all things and cling to that which is
good
resist evil always strengthen the
faint-hearted lift up the oppressed
defend the helpless honor God fear no
man above all love and serve the Lord
amen
[Music]
[Applause]
my heart
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please remain in
place as official party departs and the
colors are retired
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen thank you for
attending today's program and enjoy the
rest of your day
[Applause]
[Music]